for showrunners you spoke to incredible
names in the industry and a lot of them
said they had a compulsion to do it even
though at times they lack sleep it
interfered with personal relationships
but they kept going and they almost
couldn't stop what do you think was the
reason is that something that's a
statement about sort of the creative
process that people don't want to let go
of things no matter what it's costing
them because they're so enthralled with
the outcome I think it's a function of
the the job as well to a certain extent
I mean you you kind of have to work
those errors because you're on a
schedule and you're on a budget and you
have to deliver an episode to air at a
given date if you don't do that that
costs can end up costing millions of
dollars you can throw the whole Network
schedule into disarray so it's a
combination of they want to do the best
work that they could possibly do so
everything is kind of given as much time
and attention as it possibly can be but
it's also a function of just we have to
produce a show you know which is the
great mix between art and commerce that
they they're constantly kind of you know
battling against I think a little bit
anything it like being a parent isn't it
you know they're they're under immense
pressure from all sides and it's like
you know you get these plates spinning
at a certain rate and if you drop one
they all fall so I feel like there's the
degree of that where they have to keep
going like sharks though if they stop
swimming they'll die to some extent not
to compare them to sharks but you know I
think that once you get entrenched into
this methodology in this type of work
environment that it's very hard to take
yourself out of it and relinquish that I
wouldn't say control but relinquish the
the relinquished of control because who
else is going to do it better than you
are when you you have created this
cohesive vision for this piece of
effectively corporate art that has to be
on time and you know and requires the
immense effort
and talents of hundreds you know
sometimes thousands of people it's a lot
to manage so you've got to stay on top
of it all one of your showrunners
mentioned there's a hundred percent
burnout rate then people in their early
to mid 50s eventually say no I'm done
what do you think is the personality
type that's attracted to this not just
the creative person everybody comes here
well armed with a script in their life
story and they think oh this is gonna be
it but it takes a lot to really maintain
what 15 hour days sometimes seven days a
week yeah I think you have to be pretty
driven I think you have to be not afraid
to piss I don't know if I can say that
just to piss people off because it's
very important that you come in and be
very clear about this is my show this is
the way we're going to do things you
have answers for people when they ask
you questions it's very important to
have answers and to be making decisions
all the time and people need to you know
be convinced that what you're telling
them is the right way to go so you need
to be very you know you need to be very
certain in your own vision of show when
you starting off and very driven with it
so for people who who might be want to
be people pleasers maybe a little bit
and want to get on with everybody I
think that's a much harder sell to be a
showrunner with that kind of personality
type you need to be not afraid to kind
of annoy people to get what you want out
of them you know so I think that's
definitely one of the traits anyway I
like it how Joss Whedon referred for
himself as a maverick beginning he was
sort of the company man or maybe I'm
paraphrasing here but and then he became
more of a maverick so you think it's
more that type people that are there
willing to conform a little bit but at
some point sort of that this is my show
has to come out that that whole
ownership well in Josh's instance in
that particular quote he was referring
to the fact that he was perceived as a
maverick because he had spoken out
against the networks on a certain number
of occasions which were less than at one
hand he counted on but because he had
spoken up and those those particular
times he had somehow found out that he'd
earned a reputation as this maverick but
when in reality he's actually very much
a company man and tries to choice to be
a company man
but as far as personality types we've
seen such a breadth and scope of
personality types from very quiet and
measured and cerebral - very very good
arias and over-the-top and you know so
as far as like type a Type B I wouldn't
say that's so much the case but
confidence having a creative vision
having something to say and being
confident enough to step up and and take
the reins and manage you know the the
execution of that vision is it's a
immensely important but being able to
make decisions whether right or wrong
but being decisive and intentional
deliberate in your actions and know and
having that with that vision in mind is
is of utmost importance because if you
don't have that then someone's going to
come in and fill that gap it's going to
create a vacuum of power of vision and
of authority and administration and
everything in between so it if you
someone rushes in to fill that vacuum
they can compromise your creative vision
speaking of Joss I know that you both
tried to go the traditional route by
contacting agents and managers maybe you
had an IMDB Pro account and got those
names when you said you met Joss somehow
it was like divine intervention in a
parking lot after a meeting other than
Joss who else did you meet in an
unconventional way and what were some of
the answers that these gatekeepers gave
you when you asked for access we there's
a couple of people the way we got to
everybody was like clearly kind of
different yeah my Kelley we went to the
PaleyFest we're doing
evening or afternoon panel thing and we
tried to basically hijack them outside
on the red carpet line some people we
met at different kind of writing events
around LA as well and wherever you
wherever we kind of thought somebody
might be I think Jane Espenson we caught
a Nerdist Reuters event as well and some
people a lot of people we actually kind
of got through through the assistants
who were like very responsive to we cut
a little piece together which had a
couple of the first people that we had
on camera and we released that just kind
of within industry here and a lot of the
assistants kind of pick that up and
spread it around so it got to be a
little easier when we were calling
people that when I started to explain
what it was they kind of had seen
something and kind of had an
understanding of it and I'm that then
started to snowball a little bit once we
got one person another person or
whatever but everybody was kind of
different trying to think I mean JJ took
the longest he was a year-and-a-half to
get him but was your pitch longer shorts
are doing what were you besides showing
the clip did you kind of just you know
we had a verbal spew where we just
lashed out every name we could think of
in about 15 seconds to people saying
let's just in relation to Joss yeah it's
interesting because you know when Dez
first came out and pitched the idea and
they go wow you know that's a great idea
how are we gonna do this you know and
many people up to that pointed who were
trying to encourage him like you know
you might want to temper your
expectations this is gonna be very
difficult if not impossible you know to
get one let alone the breadth of the
scope that you need to tell a complete
story but the problem actually quickly
became how are we gonna get these very
important very busy people - oh my god
tears how are we gonna fit them all in
because now they're coming to us in in
stair instances were looking at genres
basically ringing us up because what
happens is this is a very monastic
existence that they live and they they
only interact with certain individuals
in the writers room
their lives and we discovered that you
know the writers rooms talk to each
other and the word spread very quickly
after the trailer landed and like oh my
god they got Damon Lindelof and why am I
not in this film and you know not
exactly but I'm paraphrasing what am i I
was cool enough and is once you know
Damon kind of land it in we he was
gracious enough to permit us an
interview and we were able to cut that
industry kind of clipped together and
put it out as a teaser trailer a couple
of years ago that really made it a lot
easier because then we had something to
show and gave us some sort of
credibility yeah this advice to a friend
who wants to become a showrunner do they
really want to become a show I would
question your sanity are they a writer
already just say you had it sat down had
a beer with someone that you knew from a
while back and they said you know what
I'm I'm here in LA my goal is to become
a showrunner to watch this movie yeah
first start I'm really broke cook then
come back to me and then talk about all
that yeah I mean it's it's the ambition
of a lot of people that we've met along
the way it is an incredibly difficult
job to do it's an incredibly difficult
position to get to in the first place
however things that are changing a
little bit there is a little bit more
opportunity there now because there's
now so many new outlets coming out
there's a lot of demand for creative
shows and stuff so yes there's there's a
greater possibility but it is still an
incredibly difficult job to do and to
get to